ça vous donne pas des regrets 2 est
présenté ce succès si je n'entendais que
les personnes qui viennent me voir c'est
pas que tu pouvais avoir un regret
immense parce que
elle le partage avec moi mais je suis
aussi conscient que
le temps et n'est plus celui là
maintenant il faut plus avoir d'odeur a
il faut avoir des projets d espoir et
c'est vrai que au mois décembre 2016
suis beaucoup posé la question et si ce
peuple là qui vient me voir elle avait
manifesté avec suffisamment de force et
moi même si j'étais allé à son encontre
sans doute que j'aurais réfléchi à deux
fois avant de prendre cette décision
quel rôle vous jouez aujourd'hui vous
voulez jouer
moi ce que je veux faire c'est que
d'abord les français prennent conscience
de ce que nous avons traversé ensemble
pendant cinq ans avec des épreuves aussi
avec des réussites et résultats
économiques qui sont apparues certes un
peu tard mais sont apparus est ce que je
veux aussi c'est que les socialistes et
sociaux démocrates ceux qui sont à
gauche qui veulent qu'il y ait un espoir
de justice puisse se trouver dans ce
livre des leçons pour bâtir l'avenir
et puis enfin je veux éclairer mes
concitoyens les français sur le monde et
sa dureté aujourd'hui service après
vente de ce mandat
oui peut-être n'at-il pas été fait par
d'autres donc je le fais moi-même ce
service après vente
et puis aussi parce que je pense que ce
que l'on peut retrouver dans mon
quinquennat peut permettre de formaliser
un projet politique parce que c'est une
conception d'abord de la présidence de
la république pour cette sueur humaine
c'est aussi des avancées sociales se
sont un peu perdus c'est de la justice
fiscale
elle a été là aussi occulté et donc
on peut comme chaque fois à la fois
exprimé des regrets mais aussi faire la
différence
est ce qu'il ya à sauver aujourd'hui
chez emmanuel macron en avant moi je
pense qu'il faut toujours souhaité la
réussite de son pays donc
face les choix qui notamment au plan
international sont les plus lourdes
on le voit par rapport à l'iran par
donald trump
il est très important que la france
garde son rôle de préservation de la
paix c'est la france qui peut peser dans
le destin du monde et je dis souvent
français ceux qui viennent
sachez que vous êtes dans un pays où
votre propre décision celle de faute et
peut entraîner une modification du monde
je suis très heureux de me retrouver ici
à présent soit je fais toutes les
grandes villes de france et chapeau le
même accueil et cet accueil c'est pas
simplement pour parquer de la sympathie
et la de l'amitié elle peut exister
c'est aussi pour montrer qu'il ya un
attachement aux idées que je représente